انا انا الاسد اسد انا انا الاسد انا
الاسد ملك الغابه ذو اقدام ومهابه انا
الاسد ملك الغابه ذو اقدام ومهابه اني
اقوى الحيوانات
تحسب لزئير حسابه اني اقوى الحيوانات
تحسب لزئير حسابه كان الاسد انا الاسد انا
الاسد انا الاسد انا الاسد انا الاسد انا
الاسد
بشائر اهز الاطلال فيفر الكل بالحال احيا
من
حول
ات للاشبال بزاير اعز الادغال سيسر الكل
وبالحال احيا من حولي لبؤتي تلهو من حول
الاشبال اسد اسد انا الاسد اسد اسد انا
انا الاسد
انا مفترس انا صياد
ومزاجي لو
اغضبت تجول ارض السافانا مع عائلتي
المعتاد انا مفترس انا الصياد ومزاجي لو
حاد اتجول ارض السما مع عائلتي كالمعتاد
انا الاسد ملك الغابه ذو اقدام ومهابه
مهابه اسد ملك الغابه
ذو اقدام
ومها اني اقوى الحيوانات
تحسبني
حسابك اسد اسد انا الاسد اسد اسد انا امل
اسد
انيابي ضخمه وقويه اخضع لي تلك البريه لكن
عائله الاصليه
وفصيله جنس القطط
انيابي ضخمه وقويه اخضع لي تلك البريه لكن
عائلتي الاصليه
وفصيله جنس القططيه اتت اسد انا الاسد اسد
اسد انا انا الاسد اسد اسد انا انا الاسد
انا انا الاسد
[موسيقى]